واسقاط القوات الجويه الروسيه لمسيره
امريكيه فوق البحر الاسود اعاد تسليط
الضوء على
الضوء على هذا البحر المشاهدين اذا وصراع
القوى الدوليه عليه والتوتر في هذا البحر
ليس بالجديد ودائما ما كان نقطه ساخنه بين
روسيا من جانب الدول الغربيه من جهه اخرى
معكم بشكل اكبر على البحر الاسود ست دول
تشاطئه نصفها اعضاء في النيتو وهي تركيا
رومانيا بلغاريا اضافه لاوكرانيا القريبه
من الحلف وكل من روسيا وجورجيا الوجود
البحريه الروسيه هو الاكبر في البحر
الاسود ولموسكو قاعدتان الاولى هي قاعده
في شبه جزيره القرم وتحديدا في ميناء
سباستوبول اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي يضم
سفنا حربيه صغيره وزوارقه قتاليه وسفنه
انزال وكاسحات الغام اضافه لغواصات هجينه
تعمل بالكهرباء والديزل وطائرات حامله
للصواريخ المضاده للطائرات والغواصات
الاسطول الشماليه التركيه المتمركز في
البحر الاسود يضم بدوره ايضا مقاتلات
ومروحيات وغواصات وكاسحات الغام وسفنا
مقاتله لتركيا نفود كبير على البحر الاسود
يتمثل في سيطرتها على مضيقي البوسفور بديل
المؤديين للبحر وبامكانها اغلاق المضيقين
امام حركه المرور العسكريه في اوقات الحرب
بعيدا عن تركيا وبخلاف الاسطولين التركي
والروسي تمتلك رومانيا وبلغاريا قوات
بحريه اصغر فيما لا يوجد في جورجيا سوى
خفر سواحل للبحر الاسود
[موسيقى]